Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
bem-vindos para mais uma live dos
apoiadores do Dr Alan pro canal
fechado bem hoje eu vou fazer um
pouquinho diferente eu vou responder
Primeiro as perguntas porque
recentemente tenho visto que tem sido
muitas perguntas e eu vou priorizar isso
e se a gente não atingir uma hora de
eu vou discutir alguns artigos eu sei
que eu vinha fazendo o contrário mas com
aumento do volume das perguntas tá um
pouquinho difícil seguir esse parâmetro
aí mas vamos vendo né Se vocês me derem
um feedback diferente a gente pode mudar
de novo voltar a discutir algum artigo e
talvez responder as perguntas de maneira
mais rápida mais objetiva Boa noite
Rinaldo seja muito
bem-vindo bem vou começar respondendo
primeira
pergunta deixa eu dividir a tela aqui
com
vocês deixa eu
ampliar aliás Deixa eu fazer de um outro
jeito aqui
pronto deixa ampliar
aqui primeira pergunta é do
Fernando Doutor caso possível poderia
discorrer sobre o artigo abaixo uma live
do grupo aí ele colocou um link aqui só
que acho que ele não se atentou que o
link era de uma referência do artigo
Então eu não sei se ele tava falando
exatamente do artigo
que tem nessa página ou é da referência
desse artigo mas enfim o assunto é
tiamina e
câncer a minha principal dúvida é a
quantidade de vitamina B1 necessária
para atingir o efeito citado no artigo
que fala em 75 vezes o valor recomendado
a IDR para a vitamina B1 é de 1,2 logo
esse valor de 75 vezes seria de 90 seria
mais indicado uso de benfotiamina para
aumentar a biodisponibilidade tá vamos
lá eu dei uma olhada no artigo fiz uma
revisão rápida aqui e da literatura e é
o
seguinte a tia Mina sim tem sido feito
alguns estudos em vitro em vivo mas
ainda não fizeram os ensaios clínicos tá
ela tem uma dose anticâncer
porque ela afeta uma enzima chamada
piruvato
desidrogenase Então ela ativa a piruvato
desidrogenase e essa ativação tem efeito
anticâncer
então a dose recomendada ainda não é
sabido a dose porque na verdade isso
ainda tá em estudo
o que eu posso dizer é que existe
protocolo de tiamin doses extremamente
altas por exemplo para
Parkinson duas três até 4 G por dia
então tiamina é muito seguro a
toxicidade tiamina é muito
baixa mas a dose a dose exata ainda não
foi especificada em nenhum estudo ok
no contexto da utilização da tiamina em
doenças relacionadas com câncer um autor
chamado eisenberg ou isenberg
relatou que ele usou tiamina para tratar
uma doença
chamada desculpa encefalopatia
relacionada a tiamina pessoas T
deficiência de tiamina e desenvolve uma
doença neuronal e ele pegou um subgrupo
que tava com câncer então ele verificou
com uma dose de 500 mg por via
endovenosa ou venosa três vezes por dia
foi eficaz na reversão dos sintomas
dessa encefalopatia né Por deficência de
tiamina então isso sugere que doses mais
elevadas de tiamina são bem toleradas
como eu tô falando eu conheço protocolo
que usa várias gramas por dia de
tiamina Então esse estudo é um estudo
indireto ele se concentrou no tratamento
de outra doença e não viu os efeitos
anticancerígenos diretos mas isso dá uma
segurança maior quanto ao uso de doses
altas um outro autor um outro autor
chamado istac vasca né Não sei se falei
o nome dele
certo explorou também o uso de complexo
de vitamina B com tiamina Ele estudou
isso em ratos ele administrou uma dose
alta de 110 MG por kg de ETI Amina isso
mostrou uma tendência para inibição ento
tumoral só que ele não encontrou
significância estatística nesse estudo
então isso tá muito Inicial
[Música]
ainda então eu digo para vocês que é uma
tentativa válida né num uma situação até
de desespero uma coisa assim até porque
tiamina não é caro e não é tóxico Mas a
gente não sabe exatamente qual que é a
dose ainda que seria recomendada assim
pelo que eu tô vendo aqui talvez 500 mg
três vezes ao dia seja uma dose
e aceitável para quem tá com câncer Ok
vamos pra próxima pergunta mas isso aqui
não é uma resposta definitiva como eu
expliquei Boa noite enil Fernando
castelani o castani
né pergunta do Eliseu uma conhecida tem
xque de repetição faz 15 anos indiquei
para ela comema que é 10 desde então ela
começou a tomar em xque tem melhorado
porém a partir de um certo dia sempre
que ela tinha crise enxaqueca tomava com
enzima q10 A enxaqueca dela aumentava
até que ela parou de tomar daí passei a
receitar para ela 50.000 tá receitando
né Eliseu passei a receitar para ela
50.000 unidades de vitamina D3 nas CR
chaque que tem dado certo
Existe alguma explicação para com enzima
que 10 aumentar em xaque sim dependendo
da dose que ela usou ela pode ter tido
uma
vasodilatação por conta da coenzima que
10 porque ela causa uma vasodilatação
aumento da do fluxo sanguíneo e alguns
pacientes apesar da com enzima que
geralmente baixar a pressão arterial ela
pode ter um efeito paradoxal em algumas
pessoas eem aumentar a
pressão cada pessoa é uma pessoa Cada
pessoa tem uma tolerância
Cada pessoa tem uma reação
diferente então tem que ser feito
acompanhamento médico mas pode ter sido
sim o uso frequente com eema q10 pode
ter chegado a um valor alto no sangue e
ter causado vaso dilatação a vitamina D
pode ajudar sim na enxaqueca porque ela
tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias
Ok Cuidado hein se meter aí não fica
dando um de médico
não o
próximo também do Eliseu Conforme você
disse em lives anteriores se eu faço uma
refeição às 12 horas mais ideal para não
atrapalhar na absorção é aguardar pelo
menos 2 horas para tomar os suplementos
Suponho que às 14 eu ingiro um conjunto
de suplementos nesse caso para ingerir
outro conjunto de suplementos mais ideal
para não atrapalhar a absorção também
seria
ideal ingerir 2 horas depois existe o
ideal elu existe o que é feito a maioria
das pessoas usam o ideal como
justificativa para não fazer nada então
eu não gosto muito do ideal porque o
ideal muitas vezes é inimigo do bom que
que muitas vezes é o suficiente tá Mas
respondendo
você seria ideal sim esperar duas horas
só que tem pessoas que não podem esperar
2 horas e um intervalo menor por exemplo
de 1 hora pode ser aceitável dependendo
da pessoa e dependendo do suplemento que
tiver
tomando isso novamente varia de pessoa
para
pessoa
Ok lógico se você for extremamente
regrado faço o intervalo de 2 horas mas
muitas vezes o intervalo de 1 hora já é
aceitável Boa noite Adriana Carlos
ketman boa noite
Denise próxima pergunta
quando a pessoa está com excesso de
testosterona isso é difícil de definir
né como é que defini isso porque tomou o
testosterona injeção tomou o gel
transdérmico como é que seria esse
excesso
aí às vezes não é excesso às vezes é o
exame que não tá
sabendo discernir realmente o que tá
acontecendo né exame de laboratório
especialmente hormonal tem muito
problema
Então vamos supor que está alto mesmo e
a pessoa quer diminuir a única maneira
que eu imagino para diminuir é se
estressar bastante não não faz sentido
isso
Eliseu né se você se estressa bastante
você não vai baixar a testosterona você
vai só bloquear o
receptor através do cortisol em excesso
comer um monte de porcaria também não
recomendo né não adianta nada baixar
Test na base do do infarto né Há alguma
maneira de diminuir a torana sem fazer
mal à saúde
obviamente primeiro é parar de fazer a
reposição que é o a causa disso em 99%
das vezes
né então se você consumir alimentos
ricos em fibras tá
especialmente vegetais que tenham
estrogênios
fitoestrógenos você vai reduzir a
testosterona então se você consumir
frutas legumes alguns grãos integrais
pode ajudar a reduzir Não muito mas vai
ajudar a prática de exercícios que não
seja de força exercícios
de digamos de aeróbicos né que você vai
ter aí um desgaste maior do
organismo pode ajudar yoga meditação
também pode
ajudar Existem algumas ervas suplementos
que você pode utilizar o sal palmeta ele
pode baixar DHT né de o testosterona por
exemplo e o pig africano e o antig
dioica também Poderia ajudar a
baixar existe um diurético chamado
espirona lactona que tem efeito
antiandrogênico mas só com
acompanhamento médico em doses
baixas Ok mas isso não é um problema na
prática isso aí 99% das vezes o problema
é que a pessoa está usando testosterone
de uma maneira inadequada E é só
suspender a testosterona
Eliseu poucos dias depois do famoso 11
de setembro al caída enviou pro Estados
Unidos algumas correspondências que
causaram a morte de alguns funcionários
dos Correios após eles terem sido após
eles terem tocado envelope não me lembro
se dentro do envelope havia algum vírus
tinha antras tá que era uma bactéria Ok
mas não me lembro que foi algo criado em
laboratório segundo narrativa é Foi algo
modificado não criado né né Suponha que
algo semelhante aconteça aqui no Brasil
muito Improvável Eliseu a medicina
preventiva possui alguma solução para
que a pessoa se previna Contra isso caso
a pessoa receba uma
correspondência vitamina D3 pode
proteger
disso bem o primeiro ponto aí é que só
faz sentido você tomar alguma medida se
você trabalhar recebendo muitas
correspondências por dia às vezes ser um
vendedor do Mercado Livre
né até que nesse ponto não né que o
vendedor vai mandar não vai receber mas
Digamos que você trabalha numa área de
recebimento de uma firma grande uma de
correspondência Se bem que hoje quase
tudo hoje é digital né só a mesma
encomenda que vai pelo correio Mas seria
ter um Ênio embols das mãos usar luvas
para manusear cartas
[Música]
né ficar atento a possíveis sintomas e
procurar assistência médica
imediata Não conheço nenhum suplemento
que poderia ajudar Nesse caso nem
vitamina D nem outro tá
Eliseu agora a não ser que o Brasil se
alinha aí
com de uma maneira muito forte com os
Estados Unidos em termos de guerra mande
tropas para algum país ou até se alinha
aí com a Rússia porque tá no Brick mande
tropa é muito Improvável acontecer esse
tipo de ataque no
Brasil existe terrorismo no Brasil mas
de outro tipo não
desse Fiquei sabendo que quando se
trabalha dentro de um ambiente fechado o
corpo começa a perder a capacidade de
saber quando é dia e noite se nesse
ambiente é fechado as janelas que estão
permanentemente fechadas fora e de vida
transparente a nossa consciência sabe
quando é dia e quando é noite mas o
corpo
não ô Eliseu se você tiver num ambiente
que tem janela já vai ajudar muito não
vai ser o ideal né porque vai filtrar
parte do ultravioleta mas vai
ajudar então a luz natural pode entrar
pode ajudar o corpo a manter ois o ritmo
cardiano pode assim influenciar de forma
positiva a produção de
hormônios l óo que vai variar de acordo
com a intensidade E a duração da
exposição a essa luz natural se a janela
Deixa passar mais ou menos luz e a
distância que a pessoa está da
[Música]
janela certo então isso não é uma coisa
muito relevante não eh no sentido de que
se você trabalha num ambiente muito
fechado vai dar uma caminhada no
ambiente que tenha mais luz né o Então
fique mais perto da janela Se for
possível tenta ficar ao ar livre pelo
menos três a quatro vezes durante o
horário de
trabalho especialmente durante os
horários de pico de luz solar Ok entre
10 e 16 horas dá uma sainha de a 15
minutos TR a quatro vezes por dia tenta
pegar sol Ok Isso já vai ajudar
bastante Carlos kman eh mais uma
pergunta sobre hidrogênio
molecular tive uma informação de que
hidrogênio não se mantém ativo muito
tempo dentro do corpo e portanto não
chegaria em muitos locais como cérebro
Aí disseram que o inalado nesse ponto
leva boa vantagem sim o inalado vai
levar vantagem o o ponto do hidrogênio é
como a molécula muito muito pequena é a
molécula mais antiga do universo né é a
molécula
primordial ela tem uma
difusão muito rápida pelas membranas não
tem nenhum tipo de coisa que impeça ela
entrar porque ela é muito muito pequena
é muito menor que um vírus né então ela
é extremamente pequena então ela vai
passar por tudo quanto é barreira isso
vai ajudar o hidrogênio a difundir agora
realmente não ten um estudo que eu saiba
eh provando que o hidrogênio que foi
ingerido na água hidrogenada chegou até
o cérebro né Isso aí é uma coisa que não
está ainda bem definida obviamente que o
hidrogênio respirado vai ser mais eficaz
vai difundir mais rápido no organismo e
vai atingir o cérebro melhor Ok mas
ainda Precisando de mais estudos para
poder ver o efeito do hidrogênio
molecular na água em relação o
cérebro então se você tiver necessidade
muito grande de usar o hidrogênio é
melhor usar realmente o inalado se
possível né juntamente com o o a da água
né que é
tomado vai ISO
não Maria Helena Qual que é o valor do
exame de sangue para potássio em adultos
3,5 a 4,5 tá alguns Laboratórios chegam
a 5,5 tá nanomoles por
litro se ficar acima de 5,5 você vai ter
uma hipercalemia e tiver abaixo 3,5 você
vai ter uma hipocalemia tá a hipocalemia
que é o baixo nível de potássio no
sangue vai causar fraqueza muscular
fadiga palpitação problemas cardíacos e
a hipercalemia que acima de 5 E5 vai dar
problemas cardíacos graves e pode até
matar uma pessoa com excesso de
potássio Ok então é 3,5 a 4,5 na maioria
das pessoas o limite máximo é
5,5 ess Aqui é do Thiago assisti sua
Live sobre osteoporose e tem uma dúvida
com relação ao
bifosfonato minha dúvida seria se os
efeitos colaterais são devido ao uso
contínuo sim é mais a uso contínuo ou
uma aplicação já seria suficiente é
muito difícil uma aplicação só dá
problema tá E na próxima pergunta ele
fala que é o ácido zoledrônico que ele
tá se
referindo os efeitos colaterais que a
gente pode impedir através do uso de
tocotrienóis do Urucum tá tem estudos
falando sobre isso então você pode usar
em conjunto com bifosfonato tocotrienol
do Urucum o natural Max que é um produto
lá da Active
caldic tá os efeitos colaterais mais
comuns dos bisfosfonatos
eh problemas gastrointestinais dor
abdominal e náuseas pode dar necrose
mandíbula pode também dar necrose cabeça
do fêmur
que dá uma fratura muito grave né Isso é
mais raro Mas pode
acontecer além do stois dur ucum outras
opções interessantes é você manter uma
dieta rica em cálcio vitamina D3
magnésio boro
silício manganês tud isso vai ajudar
tá a
próxima relação aos bifosfonatos
mencionado na pergunta anterior foi
prescrito ácido
eletrônico Eliane em um vídeo Lair diz
que não você deve escovar a língua e
usar raspador de língua Qual a sua
opinião eu acho que sea pessoa escovar
com a escova de uma maneira não
agressiva Vai ser tranquilo não vejo
obrigação de usar raspador mas também
raspador é barato pode comprar também tá
eu sempre esi minha língua não escovo
muito escovo pouco nunca tive problema
de machucar minha língua ou coisa do
tipo
tá porque se você usar de maneira
agressiva mesmo raspador você pode
causar lesões na língua e na
boca e também você pode prejudicar a
camada de muo natural que tem na na
língua que protege a língua
contra bactérias e outros agentes né
outros microorganismos
eu não vejo is com um problema relevante
não ok mais importante escovar o sol da
boca escovar a língua rapidinho sem
forçar se puder comprar um raspador
compre e usa o fio dental que é mais
importante ainda
né Maria Helena Você conhece alguma
marca de filtro para cloro do chuveiro
Tá eu vou colocar aqui três marcas
tá Deixa eu pôr no banner
aqui pera aí duas não vai só duas
primeiro depois eu mostro mais mais
uma Ok
ó T3 source shower Filter
aquasana shower
Filter tá e o terceiro é o Burke shower
Filter
[Música]
tá E esse aqui é o terceiro
tá vou colocar eles nos comentários
também deixa eu ver se vai tudo ou se
vai ficar faltando alguma coisa aqui no
comentário é ficou faltando não foi foi
tudo tá nos comentários também
tá próxima
pergunta Maria Helena ouvi um engenheiro
que tem uma marca de zeólita é o Thomas
Zan eu conheço não é ran não é Zan com z
eu conheço ele tá já fiz até live com
ele umas duas vezes mas tive tirado o
YouTube dizer que esse produto abaixa
pth então irá subir vitamina D não baixa
o pth mas Até onde eu sei não aumenta o
D3 tá não é então aumenta desculpa baixo
pro th mas não aumenta o
D3 Então como a zeólito é um mineral que
ajuda a reduzir a absorção de toxinas e
metais isso vai ajudar a reduzir os
níveis de pth de paratormônio porque vai
reduzir a intoxicação das
paratireoides a zeita pode ajudar a
melhorar sa de ossa por causa do Silício
que contém
[Música]
nela Existe sim uma correlação entre
vitamina D quando a vitamina D aumenta o
pth baixa Mas não é verdade que pelo pth
ter subido por causa dos zeólita que a
vitamina D automaticamente Desculpa pth
ter caído né Eh por causa da da zeólita
que a vitamina D vai subir tá não
funciona assim não Então na verdade o
pth responde a vitamina D3 mas a
vitamina D3 não responde o pth
ok ru Elita Doutor carvão ativado está
indicado para gases de excesso pode ser
usado sim mas tem que ser usado com
Cuidado em quem tem constipação tá os
gases são absorvidos pelo pelo carvão
ele pode ajudar a reduzir a
produção ali via assim a flatulência
sensação de
xaço que ele funciona como Esponja vai
capturando substâncias e gases tá é
interessante mas é para uso por pouco
tempo tá porque se você usar por muito
tempo você vai ter problemas no trânsito
vai ficar diminuindo o trâns
intestinal e pode reduzir também a
absorção de nutrientes então não use
carvão ativado o tempo todo é para
emergência e para melhorar a constipação
é dieta rica em fibras beber bastante
água praticar exercícios físicos
regulares né usar probióticos
suplementos de fibras se for
necessário Lembrando que as fibras são
prebióticas ou seja alimentas as
bactérias Marc Santana nos conteúdos
exclusivos existe fórmulas para auxiliar
no tratamento câncer mas eles podem ser
usados junto com rádio e
químio depende tá de modo geral você não
deve usar vitaminas quando for fazer a
químio e a rádio porque a vitamina foi
efeito antioxidante dependendo da dose
né obviamente porque a vitamina sem
altas dos é
oxidante Isso pode atrapalhar o efeito
da químia ou da Rádio Então depende do
nutriente e depende da dose certo então
isso é bem complexo Então tem que ser
visto caso a caso com os médicos que
estão acompanhando esse paciente se for
fitoterápico
algumas vitaminas com doses mais baixas
Sem problema nenhum mas tem que ser caso
a caso tem que ser individualizado isso
tá na dúvida não use se não tiver alguém
para
orientar agora tem protocolos que usa
cucumina que usa Resveratrol que usa
jinzen que usa tocotrienóis durante a
químio ou durante a rádio mas são
estudos ainda em andamento Não não é
conclusivo como tratar acne hormonal
numa mulher de 20 anos não usa
anticoncepcional mas não tem ovário
policístico aut Tom leite não entendi o
que que é a Tom
Leite Será que ela tirou o leite
derivados e
açúcar tá e a testa é um pouquinho
elevada tem várias medidas aí que você
pode fazer é testo elevada eu já
desconfiaria que tem sim ovário
policístico Por que que diz que não tem
ovário policístico Só porque não tem
cisto no ovário isso não é verdade
existe ovário policístico sem cisto tá
eu sei que parece estranho mas existe
porque o a síndrome de ovário
policístico não depende de ter cistos no
ovário para ter esse nome ok porque a
questão aí é o excesso de androgênios na
mulher Então se tem testo elevada pode
ser que tenha sim ou várias policísticos
Então tem que cortar os alimentos
inflamatórios da dieta açúcar alimentos
processados
industrializados cortar Leite
derivados aumentar o consumo de vegetais
de gordura saudável de
proteína grão integral também dependendo
do grão mas sem ser farinha
né aquelas coisas ser atividade física
regular sono adequado gerenciamento de
estresse estão cansados de ouvir eu
falando né habitação
tem alguns produtos específicos que eu
gosto muito para acne ao azelaico Eu
gosto bastante tá pode ser usado também
ao salicílico que é a vitamina desculpa
que é a Aspirina né mas na forma de
produto tópico tem então ácido azelaico
a o ácido salicílico O peróxido de benzu
que você encontra em qualquer farmácia
aí que é o basicão também
funciona eu uso doses baixo
espironolactona mas isso tem que ser com
acompanhamento médico porque isso aí
ajuda também a baixar o exess de
testosterona e ajuda na
acne baixa o DHT também usar óleo de
peixe ômega-3 alguns tipos de ômega-6
como é caso de óleo de prímula e borage
também vão ajudar a reduzir inflamação
Ok Existe tratamento anticoncepcional
com hormones bioidênticos mais ou menos
tá existe alguns protocolos que eu nem
conhecia eu fui estudar por causa da sua
pergunta que eu nunca fiz isso que usa
por exemplo etinil estradiol que não é
exatamente idêntico ou outros que usam o
próprio estradiol mesmo bioidêntico
junto com eh progestina e existe também
alguns ésteres de estradiol injetáveis
Então não é bem bioidêntico tá é
bioidêntico mais ou menos tá mas existe
sim hoje anticoncepcionais que usam
estradiol
eh mas pro progesterona bioidêntica não
pode usar estradiol bioidêntico junto
com progestina ou um estradiol quase
bioidêntico com progestina existe esse
protocolo sim tá Apesar de que eu não
faço ess Tipo tratamento com
consultório mas com certeza é mais
natural do que usar só coisa sintética
né é uma coisa no meio termo aí entre o
sintético e o o Real idêntico
Marilda intestino hiper permeável pode
ser causa da cí das pernas e
quietas sim pode Quais são as outras
possíveis causas dessa síndrome
deficiência de Ferro doenças renais
diabetes doenças neurológicas como
doença de paron neuropatia periférica
o próprio diabetes provoca a neuropatia
periférica danificando os nervos acúmulo
de toxinas no organismo por algum
motivo alguns medicamentos como
antidepressivos antipsicóticos também
podem causar como efeito colateral falta
de exercício físico e excesso de
estresse e
ansiedade que não foi adequadamente aí
conduzido
Então tem que pensar em deficiência de
Ferro se tiver deficiência
tratar prática de mindfulness meditação
atividade física e tratar causa
específica caso tenha sido identificado
como eu já falei
aqui certo eu gosto de usar ldn Naõ de
baixa dosagem para cim das pernas
inquietas eu acho que ajuda bem alguns
pacientes
quando uma pessoa tem bastante cálculos
biliares né Deve ser cálculo na própria
vesícula mesmo né não é cálculo colérico
Pelo
visto assim mesmo ela consegue armazenar
a b Depende se não tiver tanto cálculo
se não tiver a vesícula totalmente
tomada de cálculo Consegue sim deve
sulimar sais biliares depende de cada
caso tá bom os sais biliares são bons
Mas algumas pessoas provocam diarreia
Então tem que tomar cuidado com isso tem
que ver tolerância individual e começar
com dose
baixa essa foi a última pergunta não tem
mais
uma eu vou responder ao vivo também tá
Doutor O senhor vai participar desse
evento eu acho que sim tá tudo indica
que eu vou e vou confirmar com vocês se
eu vou participar tu interesse de
participar sim eu acabei não indo no
primeiro nem no segundo Apesar de que eu
não quero ficar muito vinculado esse
movimento para não ser perseguido Porque
infelizmente eu ajudei eles durante a
pandemia fiz bastante material para
alertar as pessoas mas paguei um preço
caro para isso né acabei zoando meu
canal do YouTube por causa disso
eh poderia discernir sobre o protocolo
para
paxon então é um médico tá Iano que
desenvolveu que já faleceu ele faleceu
na pandemia inclusive por covid ele usa
de 1 a 4 G de de tiamina por dia vai
aumentando aos pouquinhos a
dose existe também Gava intramuscular
que pode variar de 100 a 200 mg três
vezes ao dia tá é esse que é o protocolo
eu esqueci o nome do médico agora posso
olhar vou olhar aqui rapidamente na
internet Li sência pode entrar
[Música]
fil
Ah então neurologista italiano que
faleceu é o Antônio
constantini tá depois da uma pesquisada
no Dr Antônio constantini
tá Ele publicou um artigo em 2013 sobre
isso tem um site B1
parkinson.org tá se vocês quiserem se
aprofundar mais sobre isso B1 parkinsons
tudo junto b de bola 1 parkinsons com s
no
final.org tá é o site que fala disso
cápsula ozonizada óleo de girassol
funciona eu creio que
sim mas eu uso muito mais o óleo de
girassol ozonizado para tópico do que
ingerido ingerida duas horas depois de
comer vai direto pro
[Música]
intestino tudo que você come vai direto
pro intestino dizer eu não entendi a
tua dúvida aí tem que passar pelo
estômago primeiro né passar pelo esófago
pelo estômago depois intestino então
entendi essa colocação aqui faz vídeo
sobre a lul sim Já gravei vai sair
provavelmente nessa semana agora o vídeo
da alol e imo fiz um vídeo sobre os dois
adoçantes que eu nunca falei alol e
imo Boa noite Adriana boa noite Denise
Eliseu Fernando casteliano alguns eu já
dei boa noite tô
repetindo
ã verdade que as cápsulas com cores
possuem toxicidade depende da ilidade
mas eu geralmente peço pra fam fazer sem
corante na cápsula prefiro sem corante
tá metal pesado não mas o corante pode
causar
problemas então não dá para afirmar isso
que a fma Bina seja melhor não tem
estudo sobre isso para câncer Que eu
saiba não não achei pelo menos
tá beina é melhor para neuropatia
periférica tá Fernando especialmente do
diabético mas para câncer eu não posso
afirmar isso
el eu conheço o equipamento mais ou
menos eh tenho minhas reservas não tenho
certeza se esse aparelho é bom mesmo o
problema desse aparelho é que ele é
muito muito caro Então quem compra ou
Quem aluga casa com ele então é muito
difícil a pessoa se envolver com esse
equipamento e depois ela falar ah não
presta porque a pessoa se envolve tanto
se mete em dívida e então acaba casando
né e como é que vai falar mal do
equipamento Então eu tenho um pouco de
reserva por causa disso tá mas eu nunca
estudei esse assunto para te falar a
verdade então eu não posso emitir muita
opinião sobre isso tá não me senti
motivado para estudar Isso Na verdade eu
nem sei se tem artigo sobre isso eu acho
que
não consumir suplimento na pode diminuir
a quantidade
zinco não que eu saiba se você achou
alguma fonte falando isso me avise que
eu vou dar uma checada tá
Boa noite
Miria tem como saber se a tontura é
emocional adinda de uma sío de pânico
por exemplo sim excluindo outras causas
né É o jeito de saber então você tem que
excluir se não foi uma realmente um
outro problema mais sério né E aí você
pode afirmar com uma certa segurança que
foi por questões emocionais como
distinguir se é emocional ou tontura só
descartando outras causas físicas é o
único jeito de você ter certeza que é
emocional tá porque até hoje até hoje
não existe exame
para checar se o emocional está causando
as coisas de maneira
direta indica o terapeuta psicólogo
especialista em trauma trauma é muito
vago Adriana
eh você quer dizer trauma psicológico né
obviamente mas
Que tipo de trauma ptsd que é estresse
postraumático seria isso eu tenho uma
psicóloga que eu recomendo que gosto
muito que é a dout
Janaína Tá mas eu não sei se ela tem
informação nessa área de ptsd
tá se você quiser depois eu mando no o
contato da dout
Janaína eu poderia utilizar o iod kelp
para reduzir o nódulo poderia poderia
pode usar de 500 mg a desculpa de 500
microg a 1 MG por dia tá é uma dose bem
segura junto com o selenio né Tom junto
com o selenio metionina
tá É verdade que o licopen tomate só
absorvido se o tomate não não é que ele
é só absorvido aumenta bastante a bio
disponibilidade se for cozido o tomate
tá então é muito melhor cozinhar o tomá
se você quer aumentar o licopeno no
organismo então é verdade Sim qual o seu
conceito sobre suplementos da natur
sunshine eu não conheço bem esse esse
fabricante não não tem nada contra nem a
favor os melhores médicos do mundo em
ozônio são os cubanos difícil saber eles
têm mais eh experiência né de modo geral
porque lá em Cuba O ozônio não foi
perseguido então eles têm
bastante prática com o ozônio né então
poderia dizer que eles são os que TM
mais experiência de modo geral orora se
são os
melhores eu sei que foi muito
romantizado por muitos anos a formação
médica em Cuba dizendo que os médicos
cubanos eram maravilhosos que a medicina
Cubana era maravilhosa mas isso foi
propaganda realmente porque não tem como
um médico ganhando menos que um garçom
né ter qualquer tipo de estímulo para
estudar ou para aprimorar na carreira né
o cara passando fome como é que ele vai
ser um bom médico né então eu sei que é
assunto meio político mas isso meio caiu
por terra essa história que a medicina
da de Cuba é avançada e isso é conversa
fiada Pode ser que tinha lá sei lá três
clínicas em Cuba que eram avançadas para
atender americano mas fora isso a
medicina Geralda de Cuba é bem fraca
inclusive os médicos cubanos que vieram
pro Brasil eram terríveis né se é que
eles eram médicos né porque tinha muita
suspeita de que ter gente vindo para cá
sem informação nenhuma só para pegar
dinheiro do governo brasileiro né que
tinha um esquema lá do PT pegava
dinheiro público para dar salário pros
caras de Cuba Mas aí o o governo de Cuba
pegava acho que 70% do salário dos caras
tá isso que eu tô falando eu não gosto
de meter em política não gente mas eu tô
dando uma uma informação que é fato aqui
tá desculpem se vocês alguém tá
acompanhando aqui é de esquerda não vou
mais tocar nesse assunto atitude da
Glória Maria consumi 800 comprimidos de
800 não acho que é 80
né 80 comprimidos de mais menos ó por
semana Ah não você quer dizer por semana
então deve ser por semana mesmo porque
lá for acho que é 80 por dia uma coisa
assim é um exemplo a ser seguido eu
diria que paraa maioria das pessoas não
tá primeiro que a maioria das pessoas
não vai nem aguentar vai ter dor de
estômago vai não vai tolerar e porque
geralmente também eh o custo benefício
diso é altamente questionável
Tá o que que é o ta 65 é um
suplemento que é concentrado no astr
galos tá e dizem que é o melhor
suplimento do mundo de astr Galos que
teria o efeito de preservar lá a ponta
dos telômeros Tá mas isso pode ser só
uma alação do fabricante isso não é
certeza absoluta Mas tem uma boa fama
esse
suplemento Boa noite D Ana Paula
Obrigado por tá participando da Live
Você tá no carro onde é que você está ou
tá na você Dev tá em Santo André ainda
né
sim isso não sei o que ela tá falando
agora já me perdi aqui mas deve ter deve
ter falado alguma coisa que ela gostou
de nada tá
eh Boa noite a todos da D Ana
Paula a pergunta Ach para mim né se
preciso se precisar fazer exame com
contrasto com iodo recomenda
algo recomendo usar bloqueador H1 om2
antes do exame caso a pessoa não tenha
certeza que é ela pode ter alergia né eu
ten uma chance maior de ter alergia ela
pode tomar Ranitidina que é um
bloqueador H2 e um bloqueador H1
antistamínico né desses que você compra
em
farmácia para evitar a
reação e depois pode fazer também um
detox com zeólita ou com clorela ou uma
combinação de clorela Hi zeólita ou uma
combinação de zeólita com espirulina e
Aloe Vera né o Serena para tomar com
kelp pode ser absorvido com a ingestão
da castanha do
Pará Sim pode ser absorvido sim castanho
do Pará tem uma boa absorção do
selênio porque é um selênio ligado à
proteína lá na Castanha Vimos a
experiência dos médicos cubanos quando
estiveram aqui no Brasil isso é o que eu
tava comentando mir
após engerir bactéria sal salmonela
suplemento pata coloidal é ideal ideal
não sei porque não tenho esse estudo
para dizer que é ideal mas sim você pode
usar a peta coloidal Ela deve ter alguma
eficácia se vai ser uma eficácia
maravilhosa não sei dizer tá porque não
tem essa experiência pessoal para
salmonelose com prata coloidal
a estabilizante na babosa da Forever
você recomenda mesmo assim depende se
for um estabilizante natural sim tá eh a
forev tem uma
boa reputação nunca tive problema com
esse produto da Forever
não suplemento hidrossolúvel sendo
ingerido com água quente atrapalha
absorção Não não atrapalha magnésio
elementar disponível nas somas quadas é
de cerca de 20 a 30% depende do tamanho
da molécula
da do aminoácido se for por exemplo
treonato a proporção é menor chega na
volta de 11%
Tá sim carro tá vindo para casa
inac que nac ah você tá falando na pro
iodo acho que pode ajudar porque vai
aumentar os níveis de gruta no organismo
né na glicina seria ideal né na glicina
que aumentaria a gluta no
organismo um vídeo do YouTube que você
postou enquanto está viajando você disse
que é melhor tomar 100 mg mais 100 mg de
binol do que tomar 200 mg de uma vez sim
quanto mais você conseguir espalhar um
suplemento é melhor mas você consegue
fazer isso de maneira consistente esse
que é o grande ponto
né o efeito de 100 mg de binol dura
Quanto tempo não sei eu vou olhar aqui a
meia vida do bi kinol nunca procurei
saber qual que é tá vou olhar isso
agora me dá só um minuto
34 horas é bem alta a minha vida então
não pode tomar tranquilamente uma vez
por dia só
tá tranquilo como é lipo solúvel né
acaba demorando mais para ser
metabolizado
tá então respondendo sua pergunta dá
para tomar assim uma vez só ao dia
[Música]
tá se você esquecer ou se puder tomar
duas vezes melhor ainda geralmente
quando passo Bic passo duas vezes sim
por
dia bem estamos com 50 minutos quase de
Live Eu acho que eu respondi todas as
dúvidas ao vivo
aqui mas O Eliseu com certeza tem mais
umas 40 perguntas na
manga mas eu
vou comentar com vocês aqui de artigo tá
pelo menos um artigo
[Música]
né semana passada não deu tempo de falar
eu vou abrir aqui
primeiro artigo que eu vou discutir com
vocês aqui é um estudo sobre restrição
calórica com e sem exercícios físicos em
mulheres com alta porcentagem de gudura
corporal índice de massa corporal normal
então a pergunta Será que o exercício
faz diferença na perda de peso e na
composição corporal é meio óbvio que sim
né mas vamos ver aqui que esse artigo
viu né porque esse artigo tem valor
porque é um artigo que é uma metanálise
né
né E também é randomizado então esse
estudo randomizado investigou os efeitos
da restrição calórica isolada e da
restrição calórica combinada com
exercício aeróbico então combinou
restringir só caloria com restrição de
caloria com exercício aeróbico moderado
e também exercício
rigoroso Então os participantes foram
acompanhados ao longo de quatro semanas
um tempo bem curto né e um estudo chinês
em Pequim a média idade era 21 anos o Mc
na média era 21 ou seja o Mc normal e o
percentual de gordura corporal era
superior a
33% ão pessoas que tinham um percentual
de gordura elevada apesar do Mc na média
ser normal então era mulheres que tinham
excesso de gordura
corporal então eram 66 mulheres não
tinha hom nesse estudo então foram
divididos em três grupos um com
restrição calórica somente um com
restrição calórica com exercício e o
grupo controle Então os grupos com
restrição calórica e reção calórica com
exercício consumiram 500 kilocalorias a
menos do que estavam habituados por dia
em comparação com o som habitual
enquanto o grupo controle Manteve a sua
dieta normal Então as participantes dos
grupos de intervenção Escol entre três
opções de refeições prescritas e cinco
opções diferentes de lanches para
atingir as metas calóricas com
macronutrientes distribuídos em 20 a 25%
de proteína 20 a 45 20 a 45% de gordura
e 35 a 55% de carboidrato Então tinha
gente com low carbe e tinha gente com
low fat
né então o grupo que fez atividade
física também além da restrição calórica
fez sessões de corrid de esteira três
vezes por semana duração de 30 minutos
cada a uma velocidade de 8
km/h alocações adicionais de alimentos
foram fornecidas para compensar a
energia gasta durante o exercício Então
tinha uma comida a mais aí para
compensar se a atividade tinha sido
muito
intensa Então os resultados foram
interessantes em termos de perda de peso
o ambos os grupos obviamente né que de
intervenção perderam o preço tiveram
reduções
significativas então o grupo de
restrição calórica perdeu 2 kg em
comparação com controle o grupo de reção
calórica mais exercício perdeu também 2
kg curioso isso né até foi até um
pouquinho menos então o pessoal com
exercício acabou comendo mais eu acho
mesmo com esse controle aí
então em relação a índice massa
corporal grupo de reção calórica Perdeu
0,87 de Mc o pessoal que tava fazend
exício físico perdeu 0,77 Então perdeu
menos Mc do que o grupo só fez restrição
calórica em termos de percentual de
gordura corporal O pessoal que fez
restrição calórica perdeu
1,44 o pessoal que fez
a associado à restrição
o atividade física perdeu
1,48 por de gordura corporal em relação
ao controle então o pessoal da atividade
física perdeu um pouquinho mais de
gordura muito pouco na verdade em termos
de massa gorda o grupo de restrição
calórica perdeu 1,34 em relação ao
controle e o grupo com atividade física
perdeu 1,44 um pouquinho menos
também então o ponto mais importante foi
a reservação da massa muscular no grupo
que fez atividade física onde a
diferença não foi estatisticamente
significativa em comparação com a perda
significativa do grupo que só fez
restrição
calórica além disso a circunferência da
cintura e do quadril diminuiu Em ambos
os grupos de intervenção Com redução de
3,5 cm na cintura e 2,7 cm no quadril
para o grupo de restrição calórica e 2,9
na cintura menos então no grupo que fez
atividade física e 2,9 no
quadril então o quadril diminuiu mais no
grupo que fez atividade física e a
cintura diminuiu
menos o apetite aumentou no grupo de rão
calórica ao longo da intervenção mas não
mudou significativamente nos grupos que
fizeram atividade física mais restrição
e o controle então Resumindo né Qual que
é a conclusão desse estudo a restrição
calórica com sem exercício foi eficaz
para perda de peso pesar que foi um
Tempo muito curto e foi pouco peso que
esse pessoal perdeu mas perderam peso
perderam gordura e foi eficaz nessas
mulheres que tinha uma alta porcentagem
de gordura corporal e Mc bem dentro do
Normal né er as falsas magras Então esse
estudo foi interessante porque foi
estudo de falsas macras esse que é o
ponto aqui diferente desse estudo de
outros milhares de estudos
no entanto a adição de exercícios ajudou
a preservar a massa muscular que é óbvio
O que é crucial para a saúde geral e
paraa manutenção da perda de peso a
longo prazo eu falo pros pacientes se
perder muito o músculo vai ter
dificuldade depois de manter a perda de
peso tem que ganhar músculo junto com a
perda de peso de peso no sentido de
perder gordura a pessoa pode até não
perder peso pode até ganhar se esse
ganho for de músculo então mais
importante é o percentual de gordura não
é perder peso o pessoal usa o parâmetro
errado que é a balança você tem que usar
a balança de bio impedancia não é uma
balança Normal
beleza bem Vamos responder tem mais
artigos aqui masic a semana que
vem vamos responder as últimas perguntas
aqui pra gente encerrar ah ingestão de
0,5 MG de melatonina é suficiente para
atuar como antioxidante Não não é é para
induzir o sono Eliseu é bom artigo esse
Que bom que você gostou porque eu achei
até que vocês estavam meio achando esses
artigos meio chatos né Que bom que você
gostou bem pessoal ou você tá só me
elogiando porque eu reclamei que você
pergunta muito Eliseu não sei viu tô
achando que você tá suspeita Eliseu essa
esse seu comentário de elogioso e tá
suspeito ah miram amou o artigo Obrigado
Mir então talvez seja eu mesmo que eu tô
muito
cínico faz sentido ingerir 0,5 MG de
melatonina sublingual mais 0,5 MG oral
ao mesmo tempo faz porque aí ficaria uma
poção de ação mais rápida e outra
demoraria mais para absorver e uma ação
mais lenta faz sentido
sim tá vou dar uma colher de chá para
vocês aqui vou ficar mais 5 minutos tá
boa ideia colocar o artigo no final da
Live você gostou E aí pessoal quem está
acompanhando vocês preferem então que eu
começa respondendo as perguntas e só
fale o artigo no final vamos fazer uma
votação rápida aqui quem que prefere
artigo no começo e quem que prefere
artigo no final quem prefere artigo no
começo coloca número um quem prefere
artigo no final coloca número
dois beleza um e dois tá então por favor
coloquem aí um para quem quer artigo no
começo dois para quem quer artigo no
final Qual que é a suplemento para Darco
geralmente 200 mg Eliseu duas vezes ao
dia temos três votos dois aqui Eliane
miram Eliseu mais votos pessoal vote aí
Adriana um ou
dois Ok dois são quatro pessoas já se
manifestando quem mais ainda não votou
[Música]
eh Fernando castelane Você tá aí
ainda um ou dois Rinaldo Você tá aí
ainda Você saiu
enilde você está aí ainda Carlos
Denise Sim Adriana eu eu entendi que era
o dois no final
parece que o os outros saíram já do da
Live ou então não tão me escutando
mais vou ficar mais dois minutos tem
mais perguntas pessoal eu podia falar
outro artigo né mas acho que não vou
não Ou vocês querem que eu fale outro
artigo aqui rapidinho
enil tanto faz então eu vou considerar
voto nulo
OK você também acha que não temos
condições de a imitar a CCO zonas azuis
muito difícil Eliseu acho que o
principal problema de
imitar eh São comunidades pequenas que
são muito cooperativas né as pessoas
entre si eu acho que é o mais difícil de
imitar isso
eh são são eh comunidades pequenas não
são cidades grandes tá E que tem grande
cooperação entre si acho que esse é mais
difícil de imitar das das zonas
azuis D Ana Paula não tem direito de
voto Don Paula não tem direito de voto
né não tem sim vai pode voltar vai pode
voltar sim tá pessoal vamos deixar o
artigo paraa semana que
vem mais um minutinho para eu
encerrar
Ah deixa eu mostrar o
o o a o
site Na verdade são dois sites que tem
essa informação da tiamina de alta
dosagem para
paxon
ovo caipira Branco possui os mesmos
nutrientes que o caipira vermelho não o
vermelho tem mais luteína eu acho eu tem
que dar uma checada mais tem quase
certeza que tem mais
luteína conhece sal palmeto para acne
hormonal feminina Sim eu já usei Eu até
comentei agora aqui na pergunta eu falei
do sal
palmeto numa Live recente você mencionou
contraindicações protocolo Coimbra a
pessoa tem como consertar essas
contraindicações de modo a poder fazer
uso sim se tiver bem acompanhado com o
médico pode acontecer conseguir
compensar ah dout an Paula é membra não
sabia não ai ai
então
pagou pagou você tem todo direito então
Paula de fazer o que você quiser viu
Eh me indicaria salto aumento para
comprar para comprar para acne é
basicamente a mesma dose do é 200 mg
duas vezes ao dia ou 300 mg duas vezes
ao dia Onde comprar loja
suplemento ou comprar já o suplemento
pronto ou você manipula tanto
faz as duas
formas pode comprar Nal Foods pode
comprar de Doctor first tem vários
fabricantes aí
entendeu Bem pessoal Muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês já falei miram né acho
que talvez o não pegou ainda por causa
do delay né do atraso mas aí eu já falei
as marcas tá doctors first eh Life
extension eh que mais
eh acabei de falar
o tá bom pessoal um abraço para vocês
até semana que vem um beijo no coração a
Estela ué chegou agora
Estela tá atrasado Estela você volta um
ou dois Estela
um artigo no começo da live dois artigos
no final da Live que nem eu fiz hoje
respondi as dúvidas depois o artigo só
no final você volta um ou dois
tela
ui tava quietinho mas não volta
estelas tô esperando só você voltar
Estela para encerrar aqui
Então tá acho que a Estela não quer
voltar não beijo para vocês até semana
que vem ah já voltou aqui um obrigado
Estela beijo até para vocês até semana
que vem